sur les mises des affaires étrangères
mesdames messieurs les ministres
je vais d'abord décès la parole aux
noces merci bien c'était un train de
l'apprendre je vous remercie monsieur le
président de la république le corps
diplomatique accrédité auprès de votre
excellence se réjouit chaque année de
pouvoir vous rencontrer à l'occasion du
passage de la nouvelle année est de vous
manifester sa considération pour
l'action que vous menez en faveur de la
résolution des tensions qui préoccupent
la communauté internationale à quelques
jours des attentats terroristes qui ont
coûté la vie à 17 journalistes policiers
et citoyenne nous désirons tout d'abord
vous renouvelez monsieur le président la
solidarité de nos gouvernements avec les
proches des victimes et avec tout le
peuple français qui dimanche avec vous a
manifesté sa détermination à préserver
la liberté et la démocratie
au cours de l'année écoulée nous avons
pu observer avec une attention toute
particulière
l'engagement de la france en faveur de
la stabilité internationale de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
celui ci a pris une dimension nouvelle
et inattendue sous la forme d'un état
autoproclamé au mépris de toutes les
lois internationales
cet état s'est rendu responsable des
massacres et des services inouïe sur les
populations civiles qui ne partagent pas
son idéologie
j'ai tant sur les routes de l'exil
nombre considérable des personnes à la
recherche de l'accueil dans les états
voisins
la 'grande coalition' mise en place n'a
pas encore pu mettre fin à ces exactions
sur une autre terre l africaine celui là
vous avez mot sur le président porter
secours aux populations également
menacer par des organisations
terroristes
mus par la même idéologie exclusiviste
c'est l'honneur des pays libres et de
s'unir pour promouvoir un ordre
international juste et pacifique
force est de constater que le dialogue
entre les cultures se heurte souvent à
des obstacles que l'on ne croyait
surmonter presque 67 ans après la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
l'humanité n'a pas encore trouvé un
socle comme une des valeurs et des
principes qui permettent de progresser
ensemble dans le respect des conventions
profondes de chacun et des traditions
culturelles de chaque peuple
n'avons nous pas assisté à des replis
méthane en question l'universalité des
droits de l'homme et donc que
l'universalité de la notion fondamentale
de dignité de la personne humaine
nombre des conflits internationaux
trouvent leur source dans des visions du
monde apparemment inconciliables la
mondialisation économique ne suffit pas
à rendre le monde plus intégrée et plus
solidaire pour accompagner les
changements technologiques induits par
les rapides progrès scientifiques les
nations comme les personnes ont besoin
des perspectives qui promettent des
lendemains meilleurs
vous même sur le président n'avait pas
manqué d'inscrire votre action dans la
poursuite des voleurs qui sont la
liberté des personnes et la coopération
internationale l'humanité s'est réjoui
de l'extraordinaire richesse de cette
différence culturelle la liberté des
jeunes ne peut certes prospérer au
détriment de la liberté des autres
c'est pourquoi chaque culture devraient
s'efforcer de promouvoir ses propres
potentialités d'ouverture et d'accueil
de l'autre la conférence internationale
sur le climat qui vous réunirez à paris
vers la fin de cette année sera une
nouvelle occasion de constater jusqu'où
les états qui préside aux destinées de
l'humanité sont prêts à s'accorder pour
préserver leur avenir commun devant les
grands défis de l'heure qu'il s'agisse
de la paix de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie
il n'est plus possible d'apporter des
solutions isolé et concurrentes les
nations doivent coopérer pour rester
elle même et s'est développée en ce
début d'année c'est la coutume
d'exprimer des voeux
l'espérance demeure profondément ancrée
au coeur de tous les êtres humains en
considérant l'absorbant nativité qui est
celle du chef de l'état en france
nous vous souhaitons sur le président la
santé et la sérénité nécessaire pour
faire face aux lourdes obligations de
votre tâche bonnet monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ambassadeurs
je suis très sensible aux mots que vient
de prononcer le nom sont en votre nom à
tous après l'épreuve que la france a
traversé la solidarité internationale
c'est manifester avec force et symboles
à la manifestation du 11 janvier étaient
présents de nombreux chefs d'état et de
gouvernement et lorsqu'il ne pouvait
être là vous étiez vous au coeur même de
cette expression qui était une
expression d'amitié de fraternité et
aussi de dignité
les mots même que vous avez utilisé sur
le nonce
c'est effectivement une épreuve que
d'avoir une attaque qui est porté sur
notre sol par des terroristes
17 mans 17 victimes le plus lourd
attentats depuis 40 ans dans notre pays
des journalistes ont été tués parce
qu'ils étaient journalistes
des policiers ont été tués parce qu'ils
étaient policiers des juifs ont été tués
parce qu'ils étaient juifs et ils
étaient unis par cette même idée toutes
ces victimes
tous ces hommes toutes ces femmes cette
idée que la france est un pays de
liberté et c'est hélas la seule
explication que l'on puisse trouver à
leur assassinat
on a voulu assassiner la liberté les
meurtriers ont commis leur crime
au nom d'une idéologie barbare car soit
celle d'al qaïda ou de dash
c'est la même c'est celle de la haine la
france fasse
cette attaque a été capable de la
meilleure des démonstrations elle a été
d'abord digne elle a été uni nous avons
répondu également avec efficacité les
auteurs de ces atrocités ont été mis
hors d'état de nuire
grâce à l'action exemplaire des forces
de sécurité police et gendarmerie des
interpellations ou encore eu lieu cette
nuit pour connaître d'éventuelles
complicités
de même nous agissons en étroite
coopération avec nos pays voisins et
notamment en ce moment même avec la
belgique
ces actes odieux ont suscité une réponse
du peuple français à la hauteur de son
histoire et de ses valeurs et les
manifestations du 11 janvier ont été
d'une ampleur et d'une force
exceptionnelle une solidarité je le
disais c'est manifester solidarité
nationale solidarité internationale et
je veux mesdames et messieurs les
ambassadeurs vous dire combien nous
avons été sensibles et fier y compris
dans ce moment de mahler par rapport à
cette émotion qui s'est soulevée par
tous et de ses manifestations d'amitié
qui ont été adressées à la france
mes compatriotes n'oublierons jamais à
la fois cette épreuve qui les a frappés
mais également la capacité qui a été la
leur de se lever pour exprimer leur
dignité et d'horreur mobilisation mais
n'oublierons jamais non plus ce que les
pays de la communauté internationale ont
voulu signifier dans ce moment quelles
que soient nos opinions
quel que soit même nos désaccords nous
avons fait la démonstration de l'unité
de la communauté internationale face à
un ennemi
comme un qui a un nom et qu'il convient
de nommer le terrorisme
nous lui faisons la guerre ce n'est pas
une guerre contre une religion c'est une
guerre contre eux la haine les attentats
qui ont été commis à paris sont une
insulte à l'islam et dans le monde
ce sont les musulmans je le rappelle
sans cesse qui sont les premières
victimes du terrorisme pas les seuls
hélas mais qui sont d'abord confronté à
cette montée du fondamentalisme de
l'intolérance donnons donc tout fait et
je m'y emploie pour empêcher les
amalgames serait d'ailleurs faire le jeu
de ceux qui veulent semer le chaos
divisez semer la peur j'entends ici
rappeler les principes qui fondent la
position de la france à tout moment et
notamment dans cette épreuve la france
elle respecte toutes les croyances
toutes les religions nous le faisons au
nom de la laïcité
la france elle reconnaît l'apport de
toutes les cultures à notre patrimoine
commun
la france elle est attachée à la liberté
à la liberté d'expression et celle là ne
se négociera jamais elle est un principe
fondamental de notre république et
notamment la liberté de la presse
la france elle est la patrie des droits
de l'homme et donc elle doit protéger
assurer la sûreté de chaque citoyen la
france elle lutte donc de manière
implacable contre le racisme contre
l'antisémitisme contre l'islamophobie la
france
quand elle a été frappée elle s'est
rassemblée son unité et sa force même si
nous disposons aussi d'une autre force
lorsque nous sommes victimes de
violences et que nous devons répondre
mais cette force cette force du peuple
français elle sera mise au service d'une
lutte contre le terrorisme qui sera
encore renforcée dans le respect du
droit
la france sort de cette épreuve avec une
détermination intacte pour agir au plan
international nous ne cédons rien nous
ne sommes sensibles à aucune pression
d'où qu'elle vienne
nous n'avons pas peur nous agissons
parce que nous sommes la france et parce
que nous sommes conscients que la france
est attendu sur la scène internationale
pour promouvoir des valeurs que nous
partageons
je veux ici saluer le travail
remarquable du mini affaires étrangères
laurent fabius qui crée les conditions
de cette action à la tête de la
diplomatie française
notre réponse doit être ferme face au
terrorisme
mais elle ne peut être que collective
chacun de nos pays doit prendre toutes
les mesures nécessaires et il y en a
encore à introduire notamment par
rapport au phénomène des combattants
étrangers qui vont sur les terrains de
guerre pour y être entraînés puis
reviennent dans nos pays commettre le
pire c'est ce qui s'est encore produit
un tiers des 40000 jihadi ce qu'ils
agissent en irak en syrie sont étrangers
à la région
nous devons donc améliorer la
coopération internationale mieux
partager les informations nécessaires
sur les déplacements les soutiens les
financements dont les terroristes
également bénéficier nous devons aussi
mieux combattre tous les trafics car
tous les trafics alimente le terrorisme
trafics d'armes trafic de drogue mais
aussi trafic des êtres humains
l'europe doit également durcir son
dispositif une réunion des ministres des
affaires étrangères européens sera
organisée dans quelques jours après
qu'il y ait eu déjà une réunion des
ministres de l'intérieur et le conseil
européens abordera cette question de la
sécurité de la lutte contre le
terrorisme en février prochain
ce que l'europe a faim c'est de mieux
contrôler le franchissement des
frontières extérieures de l'union
c'est également d'établir ce qu'on
appelle un pnr européen parlons simple
un fichier qui permettra un échange des
données concernant les passagers des
transports aériens entre les états
membres
c'est une condition indispensable pour
contrôler les déplacements des apprentis
terroristes ou de ceux qui sont déjà
dans ce combat contre nos libertés
ce fichier qui ne doit pas mettre en
cause la protection des données mais ce
fichier est indispensable pour suivre
justement ceux qui se rendent aux moyens
au moyen-orient ou en reviennent
nous devons également prendre conscience
qu'internet joue un rôle et donc
l'utilisation qui est faite par les
terroristes de cette technologie de ces
informations pour diffuser leurs
messages assurer le recrutement de
nouveaux djihadistes l'ordonné même les
moyens de passer à l'acte oui nous
devons agir avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés pour qu'internet ne puisse pas
être un moyen de préparer
d'engager des actions terroristes mais
au-delà de ces mesures indispensables la
plus durable des réponses c'est une
action ferme en faveur de la paix et de
la sécurité internationales car nous le
savons les conflits qui ne sont pas
résolues et quelquefois depuis trop
longtemps sont des sources d'inspiration
pour les terroristes et les zones de
chaos des lieux de formation pour les
terroristes
la france donc depuis plusieurs années
et notamment depuis ces deux dernières
années prend sa part dans l'action
exerce ses responsabilités avec le
concours de ses alliés de ses
partenaires au mali d'abord où nous
avons évité que les terroristes
s'emparent tout simplement d'un état au
sahel
même si l'opération au mali connaît
maintenant une phase différente ce qui
n'est plus celle de l'action mais qui
est celle de la stabilité au sel
notre vigilance reste extrême c'est
pourquoi la france a mis en place ce que
nous avons appelé l'opération barkan qui
permet d'infliger des pertes aux
organisations terroristes et d'être
présent dans l'ensemble de la zone pas
simplement au mali éviter le chaos c'est
ce que nous avons fait aussi en
république centrafricaine permettant à
nos forces de séparer les belligérants
qui voulait organiser des massacres et
nous avons grâce à nos amis africains et
maintenant avec la force internationale
qui se déploie permis à ce pays de
retrouver une forme de stabilité mais
nous n'avons pas terminé
j'ai évoqué le cesne l'afrique de
l'ouest le nigeria où boko haram se
livrent à un véritable crime contre
l'humanité ce ne sont plus simplement
des femmes qui sont enlevés c'est déjà
suffisamment atroce ce sont des enfants
qui se trouvent massacrés par les
actions de ce groupe
ce sont des
villages des villes entières qui sont
rasés alors là encore nous devons
soutenir c'est ce que fait la france les
pays qui sont concernés par ce fléau
le nigeria et c'était le sens de
l'initiative que nous avions prise de
réunir à paris avec le nigeria tous les
pays qui pouvait être utile pour lutter
contre boko haram et aujourd'hui ce sont
le cameroun le niger le tchad le bénin
qui sont menacés cette situation exige
de la communauté internationale de
prendre les mesures appropriées et de ne
pas laisser faire la situation en libye
est pour beaucoup dans la diffusion du
terrorisme et c'est un sujet
d'inquiétude majeur
notre devoir c'est de mobiliser une fois
encore grâce à l'intervention d'ailleurs
des nations unies les parties prenantes
qui doivent s'engager dans des
négociations il ya eu un accord ce matin
à genève qui va dans la bonne direction
permettant la formation d'un
gouvernement unique ce qui est quand
même un principe indispensable quand il
y a deux gouvernements dans un même pays
c'est qu'il ya quand même un problème
surtout quand il ya aussi deux
parlements
donc le premier devoir que nous devons
manifester à l'égard de la libye s'est
constitué par les parties prenantes un
gouvernement et ensuite de désarmer les
groupes qui se sont installés en libye
et de pouvoir ensuite agir contre les
terroristes qui occupent une partie du
territoire libyen et menacent toute la
région
mais la france ne peut pas même s'il est
appelé à agir seul ou agir en dehors du
droit international nous appelons donc
les nations unies c'est leur rôle pour
qu'il y ait des initiatives qu'ils
puissent être prises et des soutiens
qu'ils puissent être apportées au
moyen-orient l'urgence c'est de
combattre dash la france là encore à
ses responsabilités c'est l'opération
shamal dans le cadre de la coalition
nous apportons tout notre soutien aux
forces irakiennes qui sont engagés en
première ligne contre les djihadistes et
ses opérations militaires en irak seront
poursuivis aux côtés des autorités de
bagdad
avant-hier j'étais sur le porte avions
charles de gaulle qui a appareillé et se
rendra dans la région et permettra de
recueillir des informations précieuses
d'avoir des coopérations utile avec les
pays de cette région et de pouvoir
prendre si nécessaire une part dans
notre intervention en syrie
nous poursuivons l'action de soutien à
l'opposition modérée à l'opposition
démocratique celle que nous avons
toujours encouragé
je ne reviens pas sur ce que j'ai dit
plusieurs fois quand une intervention de
la communauté internationale est
repoussé quand elle est reportée pour
des raisons qui sont toujours évoqués au
nom du droit ou au nom de l' opportunité
alors c'est la communauté interationale
elle même qui se met en danger
aujourd'hui nous faisons en sorte que
ceux qui s'auto au combat et je pense
notamment à ceux qui luttent à koba né
et qui font preuve d'un très grand
courage puisse avoir tout notre soutien
nous sommes aussi conscients qu à alep
se prépare des combats qui peuvent être
extrêmement dangereux pour la population
trois cent mille personnes sont en cause
dois-je rappeler que de ne pas avoir
réglé la question syrienne a conduit une
partie de la population dont seulement à
se déplacer mais à se réfugier à se
réfugier en jordanie à se réfugier en
turquie à se réfugier au liban créant
d'ailleurs de grave
problèmes économiques financiers et
humains humanitaire pour les pays
concernés et l'idée que ces populations
resteront dans la région est une idée
simple tellement simple qu'elle devient
simpliste bien sûr que si rien n'est
réglé une partie de cette population
voudra aussi aller vers l'europe tentera
d'y venir et nous devrions à ce
moment-là réfléchir sur les conséquences
que de tels mouvements pourraient
engendrer alors en syrie bachar el-assad
porte une responsabilité énorme dans la
tragédie
et personne ne peut croire en tout cas
pas nous qu'il puisse rassembler son
peuple après tant de massacres et
l'alternative ne peut être
assad où les terroristes puisque c'est
finalement la même chose car aujourd'hui
ils s'entretiennent mutuellement
donc quelle est la position de la france
et de notre diplomatie chercher un
accord entre le régime
s'il veut ouvrir cette transition et les
mouvements de l'opposition syrienne
nous devrons donc reprendre ce qu'on a
appelé le processus de genève
la france est prête à y travailler avec
les nations unies et avec tous les pays
qui ont une influence en syrie parce que
la france dialogue avec tous c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait aussi la réalité
de sa diplomatie
la france elle est disponible pour
travailler avec tous ceux qui peuplent
qui veulent contribuer à la solution des
crises au moyen-orient
c'est ce que nous avons fait notamment
au liban où a été mis en oeuvre un
important accord passé avec l'arabie
saoudite pour renforcer les capacités
opérationnelles de l'armée libanaise et
lui permettent de mieux protéger son
territoire mais je veux également
dire que l'iran à sa part aussi de
responsabilité pour le règlement de ces
crises c'est ce que j'ai dit au
président rani que j'ai rencontré à new
york en septembre dernier
l'iran doit clarifier ses positions ses
intentions et s'impliquer dans la
résolution des crises enfin pour rester
dans cette région si meurtri il y a
également gaza et ce qui s'est produit
cet été qui doit une fois encore nous
conduire à réfléchir à la meilleure
façon de mettre un terme au conflit
israélo-palestinien depuis avril et
l'arrêt des pourparlers de paix la
situation s'est détériorée
il ya ce qui s'est passé avec la
tragédie de gaza
il y a aussi une escalade
elle risque d'embrasement pour conjurer
ces menaces
la france a la volonté une volonté qui
est de trouver une issue parce qu'elle a
pour israël une amitié indéfectible et
que la france est aussi l'ami du peuple
palestinien il nous faut faire vite la
solution des deux états est la seule
possible chacun en convient ne la
laissons pas s'éloigner le processus de
paix qui a été tant de fois engagé hélas
tant de fois inabouti ce processus de
paix les parties en présence ne peuvent
y parvenir seul pour le conclure il nous
revient donc de fixer les paramètres qui
sont connues et reconnues
internationalement pour donner une
solution
cet effort collectif doit s'appuyer sur
un fondement incontestable qui ne peut
être que le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et c'est pourquoi la
france a voulu présenter sous la forme
d'une résolution
une méthode constructive et consensuelle
elle y est encore prête
je sais aussi que nous devons agir
pour que les conditions de la paix
puissent être réunies pour régler la
question du dossier du nucléaire iranien
à vienne en novembre dernier nous avons
fait le constat des difficultés qu'ils
demeuraient notamment sur la question de
l'enrichissement de la production des
matières fissibles et il a été décidé de
prolonger l'accord intérimaire jusqu'au
30 juin 2015
la france veut un accord définitif mais
pas n'importe quelles conditions
avec une ligne claire oui à l'accès de
l'iran au nucléaire civil non à son
accès à l'arme nucléaire et nous ne
transigerons pas sur ce principe
nous voulons un accord mais un accord
qui aboutissent à ce résultat
agir pour la paix c'est ce que la france
fait y compris en europe car il y à un
conflit sur le continent européen
c'est la crise du crédit n depuis des
mois je me suis fortement engagé avec
angela merkel la chancelière d'allemagne
pour chercher une solution pour faire en
sorte qu' il puisse y avoir un retour à
la paix et une situation humanitaire qui
puisse ne plus être dégradée là encore
les conditions d'une sortie de crise
sont connus
c'est la mise en oeuvre complète du
protocole de minsk qui a été adoptée le
5 septembre dernier
depuis cette date il y à eut hélas une
dégradation
le non respect du cessez le feu et des
morts de nombreux morts
depuis quelques semaines il y a eu
d'autres signes qui ont été envoyés plus
encourageant même s'il ya encore des
morts à l'est de l'ukraine un nouveau
cessez le feu est entré en vigueur le 9
décembre des échanges de prisonniers
sont intervenus pour noël
les ministres des affaires étrangères se
sont réunis dans le format normandie il
y a quelques jours avec la perspective
d'une rencontre à astana avec
l'allemagne la france mais aussi
l'ukraine et la russie
la priorité ça doit être de réussir
cette rencontre d'astana mais ne venez
pas nous n'allons pas nous réunir
simplement pour faire des constats il
n'y aura de réunions installa que s'il
ya des résultats
nous avons plusieurs objectifs d'abord
la délimitation de la ligne de
démarcation le retrait des armes lourdes
des modalités d'acheminement de l'aide
humanitaire dans les régions de donetsk
et de l'ouganda et ensuite il puisse y
avoir des élections dans l'est de
l'ukraine permettant dans le respect de
la loi ukrainienne
la représentation de tous ces conditions
ne sont pas hors d'atteinte et de devons
y travailler
ce que je fais en très bonne harmonie
avec la chancelière
parce que nous sommes directement
concernés parce que nous sommes attachés
aussi à ce que l'europe et la russie
retrouve des relations de confiance est
également et une perspective commune de
développement car ce conflit coûte cher
il coûte cher d'abord humainement
puisque il y à une situation très
dégradée en ukraine
il coûte cher politiquement avec eux un
éloignement qui s'est produit des
sanctions qui ont été prononcés il coûte
cher économiquement à la russie mais à
l'ensemble de la région à l'europe
également il est donc temps plus que
tout que l'accord soit trouvée
je suis allé aussi à moscou pour
s'entretenir avec le président poutine
parce que la france avec la russie une
relation historique et que nous devons
utiliser ce lien
pour que la russie reviennent dans cette
relation que je souhaite encore affermir
entre l'europe et ce grand pays
mais faut-il aussi que la russie fasse
les gestes indispensables qui sont
attendus d'elle nous y travaillons mais
c'est aujourd'hui une responsabilité que
le président poutine doit exercer des
crises elles ne sont pas seulement
politique sécuritaire elles sont aussi
sanitaire face à l'épidémie d'ebola la
france n'a encore pas tout seul
heureusement s'est mobilisée notamment
en guinée pour construire de nouveaux
centres pour accueillir les malades pour
former et traiter les personnels
soignants qui sont les plus exposés
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et c'est une bonne nouvelle indique
qu'il ya une baisse de cas dans les
trois pays les plus touchés mais là
encore le combat n'est pas fini
la lutte contre les pandémies est une
priorité
la france maintient et maintiendra à la
disposition du fonds mondial de lutte
contre le sida le paludisme la
tuberculose
les sommes sur lesquelles nous sommes
engagés 360 millions d'euros
de la même manière si l'épidémie d'ebola
nous a conduits à prélever en urgence 25
millions d'euros sur notre contribution
à une itt aide financée par la taxe sur
les billets d'avion
ces crédits seront rétablis en 2015
parce que nous considérons que la lutte
contre les épines et fait partie aussi
de notre propre sécurité et qu'il s'agit
à la fois de solidarité mais aussi de
stabilité pour l'ensemble du monde cette
année
justement nous allons prendre la france
une responsabilité particulière puisque
nous allons accueillir la conférence sur
le climat à paris c'est un rendez vous
que le monde avec lui même le constat
non et claire établi les phénomènes
climatiques extrêmes se multiplient
partout
il touche en premier les plus pauvres et
les plus vulnérables provoque des
déplacements de populations qui peuvent
entraîner de nombreux conflits là encore
nous connaissons les conditions d'un
succès c'est-à-dire aboutir un accord
mondial engageant 196 pays pour que la
température du globe n'augmente pas de
plus de 2 degrés faire en sorte que
chacun des pays et ce sera le moment le
plus crucial annonce ses engagements
avant l'été un agenda des solutions
accompagnera la transition nécessaire
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
il nous faudra multiplier les
opportunités économiques que cet
engagement va permettre mais il nous
faudra aussi lever des fonds pour
assurer la transition énergétique
la première capitalisation du fonds vert
a vu le jour avec 10 milliards de
dollars prévus entre 2015 et 2018
nous sommes très loin encore très loin
de l'objectif qui est de dégager 100
milliards de dollars à partir de 2020
nous devons donc intensifier tous les
efforts sollicité tous les engagements
de manière à ce que des financements
innovants puissent ajouter aussi aux
contributions des états nous sommes
également conscients qu'il ya eu un
échec très grave
à copenhague nous avons tiré toutes les
conclusions et donc ne l'ont pas
attendre la conférence de paris pour
réussir un accord de cette importance là
encore attendre
ce serait prendre un risque considérable
pour la planète
nous partons de la conférence de lima
qui s'est tenu en décembre qui a permis
d'établir une base de travail pour la
conférence de paris et je salue à cet
égard l'action menée par le pérou où je
me rendrai dans les prochaines semaines
à partir de ce travail là
la france va agir avec trois principes
le premier c'est l' écoute je sais que
parmi les pays que vous représentez
beaucoup s'interrogent sur la
responsabilité que chacun doit prendre
l'engagement la france entendre à
chacune de vos préoccupations pour les
prendre en compte et faire en sorte qu'
il y est le second principe qu'ils
puissent être posé celui de l'équité
l'accord qui devra être obtenu à paris
devra être différencié en fonction de la
situation de chaque pays de son niveau
de développement et les pays les plus
vulnérables les plus fragiles les pays
émergents aussi devront être accompagnés
d'où le rôle du fonds vert le troisième
principe c'est celui de la volonté parce
que s'il n'y a pas cette volonté il n'y
aura pas d'accord et il y aura toujours
un bon prétexte pour ne pas signer le
jour venu et nous savons que s'il n'y a
pas de signature
il n'y aura plus d'accord sur le climat
avant longtemps et que ce n'est pas
simplement d'éviter que la planète se
réchauffe de 2 degrés
ce sera d'empêcher qu'elle ne se
réchauffe 2,3 2,4 degrés c'est ce que
les experts nous disent et je crains
qu'il n'ait raison
la préparation de ce qu'on appelle la
coop 21 sera conduite par laurent fabius
sous l'égide des nations unies
tout le gouvernement français et
notamment la ministre de l'écologie tout
le gouvernement français est pleinement
mobilisé pour préparer ce rendez vous
essentiel qui associera les sociétés
civiles mais aussi des entreprises les
chercheurs les jeunes de tous les pays
je m'y engagerai personnellement j'irai
partout où la voix non pas de la france
la voix du pays organisateur de cette
conférence peut être entendu à davos
pour m'adresser aux entreprises
j'irai aux philippines avec nicolas
hulot avec de nombreuses personnalités
qui ont fait de la préservation de la
planète le combat de leur vie pour
justement lancé une mobilisation
j'irai avec le président aquino sur les
zones qui ont été les plus touchées par
la catastrophe climatique
donc à chaque fois qu'il sera possible
de mettre dans l'agenda international
la question du climat la france y mettra
toute la force de sa diplomatie
notamment pour le g7 et pour le g20 je
mènerai toutes les discussions qui
seront nécessaires au plus haut niveau
avec les chefs d'état des pays que vous
représentez à la conférence de paris ce
ne sont pas les chefs d'état qui sont
les négociateurs
il faut bien comprendre cette réalité
donc c'est chaque pays qui doit
mobiliser sa société mobiliser ses
acteurs bien sûr les gouvernements que
vous représentez pour aboutir un accord
à la conférence de paris mais les chefs
d'états à un moment sont devant aussi
des choix j'ai salué ce qu'avait été par
exemple la déclaration du président
obama pour ce qui concerne les états
unis l'engagement de la chine qui pour
la première fois pays le plus émetteur
de co2 a confirmé que la chine
s'inscrivait dans ce processus et c'est
très important
et puis il y à de nombreux pays
émergents qui nous ont dit aussi que il
ne voulait pas voir leur croissance et
leur développement mise en cause mais
qu'en même temps ils étaient conscients
que si l'accord était juste alors il le
signerait et chefs d'état les chefs de
gouvernement seront jugés et nous
forcément les premiers sur notre
capacité à pouvoir dépasser un certain
nombre de contraintes de préjugés
parfois d'intérêt pour nous placer au
niveau qui convient le niveau de la
planète
il y a aussi dans cette question du
climat un enjeu écologique chacun l'aura
compris mais également un enjeu
économique
nous devons comprendre que
à travers les engagements qui vont être
prises c'est une chance pour la
croissance
c'est une opportunité pour les
technologies pour les innovations
il y aura même un critère de
compétitivité qui ne sera pas simplement
celui des prix ou celui de la qualité
des produits mais de leur contenu en
terme d'écologie et d'environnement
ce seront les pays qui seront les plus
en avance sur le plan de la transition
énergétique qui seront demain les plus
compétitifs
de ce point de vue la france non pas
parce qu'elle voulait montrer l'exemple
même si ça peut parfois être notre
tempérament mais la france fait voter
une loi sur la transition énergétique
qui va bientôt arriver au sénat et qui
marquera les objectifs qui sont
parfaitement ce que nous défendons au
plan européen et au plan international
la diplomatie française est une
diplomatie qui servent des idéaux qui
sert des principes qui sert la paix mais
qui sert aussi la croissance et la
compétitivité la concurrence
internationale
elle est de plus en plus vives elle se
trouve dans tous les domaines les
échanges commerciaux les investissements
mais également l'enseignement supérieur
la recherche le tourisme dans ce
contexte la france ne fait le choix ni
de la passivité qui serait en fait celui
de la soumission ni le choix du repli
sur soi qui d'ailleurs n'aurait aucun
avenir et qui d'ailleurs ne permettrait
pas de protéger non plus le passé parce
que l'histoire de la france est une
histoire qui a toujours été celle de
l'avant garde toujours été du mouvement
de l'anticipation et pas plus que nous
n'avons peur du terrorisme nous avons
nous avons peur de la concurrence ou de
la mondialisation
nous savons que le monde d'aujourd'hui
nous oblige nous oblige à être à la
pointe de l'innovation être mobile aller
chercher les marchés les secteurs qui se
développent et c'est ce que nous faisons
pour améliorer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
is pour développer leurs exportations et
pour renforcer l'attractivité de ce
qu'on appelle le site france la france
notre pays a dit mme ans à tous de
l'aéronautique jusqu aux technologies
vertes en passant par la gastronomie les
industries culturelles
ce qui fait la france la france elle
doit se réformer elle le fait la france
elle entend aussi mieux faire connaître
ses performances au plan international
ce qu'on appelle l'image de la france la
france à la donnée la plus belle image
lorsqu'elle a été attaquée celle d'un
peuple qui se met en mouvement autour de
sa dignité sa liberté ce qui fait notre
fierté
cette image là elle était également au
plan culturel ou plan linguistique la
langue française que nous voulons
promouvoir et qui est la propriété de
tous ses locuteurs
je salue ici la secrétaire général de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
la france elle a également une
compétitivité qui n'est pas simplement
sur ses produits mais qui est sûr aussi
c'est innovation ses recherches ses
talents pour nous recevoir un prix nobel
d'une certaine façon c'est montrer notre
compétitivité nous avons aussi la
volonté de mieux nous faire connaître
quant à nos réussites je pense que sur
nos faiblesses
certains sont point suffisamment allait
promouvoir pour que nous n'ayons pas à
insister davantage mais en revanche sur
ce qui fait nos forces de qualité nous
pouvons faire mieux que nous ne faisons
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons créé une nouvelle
agence business france business est un
mot français et et france je n'ai pas
besoin d'insister qui a été créée au 1er
janvier de cette année et qui lancera
une campagne créative france parce que
la créativité
c
la singularité de la france là messieurs
les ambassadeurs vous m'avez adressées
vous veut dans une circonstance
particulièrement éprouvante et
douloureuse
mais ce qui fait la force d'un veut
c'est qu'ils puissent être exaucé lequel
puis-je adressé au monde de retrouver
les conditions de la paix sûrement de
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent être
rendez vous avec le rendez vous avec lui
même c'est à dire avec son futur
c'est l'enjeu du climat que nous
puissions aussi avoir davantage de
prospérité lutter contre les inégalités
c'est ce que vous appelez la dignité
humaine la dignité humaine
c'est ce qui doit mobiliser plus que
jamais
l'action de la france et la communauté
internationale la france est une grande
nation qui agit pour l qui agit pour le
monde et qui agit avec l'europe union
européenne est sortie de la crise mais
n'a pas encore retrouvé la croissance
simple qui permet de réduire le chômage
ce doit être sa priorité c'est le sens
du plan juncker je viens de quitter le
président de la commission européenne et
qui m'a confirmé que l'union européenne
mais très rapidement en place toutes les
procédures tout les dispositifs
permettant à ce plan de rentrer en
vigueur
la croissance c'est aussi ce que
recherche la banque centrale européenne
qui sur le plan de l'inflation a atteint
tous ses objectifs
puisqu'elle est quasiment nul
aujourd'hui en europe et je veux saluer
son action
l'euro retrouve une parité plus conforme
à ses fondamentaux et le niveau du prix
du pétrole qui ne doit pas ralentir nos
efforts d'économie d'énergie améliore le
pouvoir d'achat de des ménages français
déménagent d'ailleurs européens et les
marges des entreprises
l'europe doit accompagner ce mouvement
en se tournant résolument vers l'avenir
le numérique les instants les uns france
culture la transition énergétique
l'économie verte
l'europe doit prendre aussi davantage de
responsabilités sur le plan politique
pour régler des conflits à ses
frontières pour parler à l'autre rive de
la méditerranée
et pour aller plus loin même dans son
action internationale partout où est
attendu où il est espéré
je souhaite qu'il y ait des accords
entre europe amérique latine y
travaillons europe et asie europe
également avec eux tout ce qui fait
l'ensemble du continent européen
c'est à dire aussi ce qui se passe à
l'est et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai indiqué qu'avec la russie nous
devions trouver une nouvelle méthode et
une nouvelle confiance
l'europe doit être plus actives sur le
plan international doit être aussi plus
vigilante sur le plan de sa sécurité
j'en ai évoqué les grandes lignes à
l'occasion de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
l'europe elle doit être plus actif dans
la question des réfugiés mais aussi dans
la lutte contre l'immigration l'europe
elle doit revoir ses instruments ses
méthodes ses ambitions le nouveau
président du conseil européen donald
tusk est également sur cette ligne de
conduite comme le président de la
commission européenne mais je veux
terminer par une réflexion qu'il ne vaut
pas que pour l'europe ou que pour la
france qui vaut pour le monde
quand les menaces se renforce quand les
risques se multiplient
quand le malheur frappe les peuples
peuvent prendre peur se replier se
rétracter sur eux mêmes se perdre dans
les extrémismes et les excès nous en
voyons déjà les signes y compris sur le
continent européen
ils ne sont plus avant coureurs ils sont
autant d' alerte mais les peuples
peuvent aussi choisir une autre voie et
pop peuvent se lever pour proclamer leur
attachement à un des principes qui
fondent leurs identités des peuples
peuvent également porter un idéal qui
les dépassent les peuples peuvent
susciter une mobilisation mais peuples
peuvent également mettre leurs
dirigeants dans l'obligation d'agir
bref tout revient toujours vers le
peuple et le peuple peut lever une
espérance et entraîner les autres c'est
ce qu'a fait le peuple français le 11
janvier dernier
non pas pour délivrer une leçon mais
pour être fidèle au message universel de
la france car le meilleur service que
mon pays puisse rendre à la planète
c'est de pouvoir être utile et c'est ce
qu'il fera tout au long de l'année 2015
c'est le voeu que je formule dans cet
instant dans cette période où beaucoup
sont éprouvés et où l'espérance reste
encore la force collective
merci